Hello and welcome to a tale of analysis and design, featuring
Spencer Rugaber, as the librarian, and Alex Orso,
as the software engineer. [SOUND]
>> Hi! I'm here waiting for Spencer, my librarian friend. He needs some
help developing an information system for a library. So I asked him to write
down the requirements for the libra... Oh, [SOUND] that must be him.
>> Hello Alex.
>> Hey Spencer. How's it going?
>> Good. Did you get those requirements I emailed you?
>> Oh, you emailed them. Now let me check.
And, by the way, get some coffee for you here.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Oh yeah. They're right here. Let me see. Oh, good. Oh, yeah,
good. We have, what we need. So the, the way I like to do
this is. I like to start by
looking at the requirements and identifying the nouns
in the requirements, because those tell us
the kind of the relevant elements in the,
in the requirements. So if you don't mind we can start looking at those and
you can tell me you know, whether the ones that I am identifying make sense or not.
>> Sounds good.
>> All right.